ayé bonjour ce procès il aura valeur de
test pour le système judiciaire
ukrainien ça devrait être le premier
d'une longue série d'une longue série
parce qu'effectivement il y as depuis le
début du conflit d'abord pas mal de
vidéos qui ont circulé ça c'est un petit
peu la nouveauté du 21e siècle on se
rend compte que il ya de plus en plus
d'imagés que donc on peut se rendre
compte rapidement de ce qui se passe
même si on n'a pas forcément tous les
éléments pour bien comprendre c'est
toujours compliqué de savoir comment
est-ce que des militaires quand ils sont
dans une position de combat tirent sur
des civils
on le voit facilement si les personnes
sont totalement désarmé si vous avez les
mains en l'air là dans le cas qui nous
est rapportée la personne de 62 ans
aurait croisé les militaires à vélo
chemin inverse si c'est le cas on se
rend bien compte effectivement qu'il n'y
avait pas une menace et que donc ils ont
choisi de tirer sur cette personne parce
qu'il ne voulait pas une dénonciation
reste à prouver réellement que c'est ça
mais c'est compliqué qui à chaque fois
dans un conflit de définir comment est
ce que les militaires doivent gérer une
situation où potentiellement les hommes
peuvent être armés puisque je vis de
l'ue elle dit avoir obéi aux ordres oui
oui mais quand bien même on est
responsable aussi de ces de ses actes
même si derrière il ya une chaîne
hiérarchique mais c'est vrai qu'en
ukraine les hommes sont armés
aujourd'hui et que donc du coup la
dangerosité existe donc on se retrouve
dans des situations qui sont
effectivement des situations très claire
de tirent sur des civils
quand c'est des femmes des enfants il ya
aucun doute quand on voit aussi que ce
sont des personnes qui sont éloignés
aucun doute mais alors ce qu'ils on se
retrouve dans les situations plus
compliquées il va falloir le définir ce
qui veut dire qu'il va falloir avoir des
qualités d' enquête qui va falloir que
la cpi fasse attention aussi
effectivement à ce qu'elle va dire à la
fois ça rassure la population à la fois
ça va très vite parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'on est encore sur le rythme de
l'émotion est à la fois sa demande aux
ukrainiens d'être très équilibré c'est à
dire que ce qui va falloir qu'ils
reprochent aux soldats russes il va
falloir qu'il fasse très attention
du côté de chez eux on a eu dans un
article du monde dernièrement des faits
qui relatait une vidéo dans lequel des
volontaires du côté ukrainien torturait
ya des soldats russes là encore si
jamais ces crimes de guerre et donc ça
peut être traité de la même manière